in collaboration with Liverpool Football
Club uh Peter is uh re staff research
scientist at Google Deep Mind a
Affiliated lecturer at University of
Cambridge uh where he obtained his uh
PhD as well he's recognized for uh his
Works in graph attention networks and uh
deep graph
Infomax better the stages Ys
right thank you very much Vash for the
fine introduction and uh thank you to
all who are tuning in for uh my talk
today as mentioned my name is PETA
valovich staff research scientist at
Deep Mind and affiliate lecturer at the
University of Cambridge and for today's
session we'll be talking about designing
an AI assistant for football tactics
which uh was a pretty exciting and I
must say really fun collaboration that
I've uh had a chance to partic dispa in
over the past couple of years and
finally we're starting to see some
concrete products out of it which uh
which I'm very pleased about so uh let's
dive ahead first into the topic when we
say AI for sports what do we really mean
it might appear to be somewhat obvious
but uh I feel like it is useful to try
to uh put some concrete pointers on what
we mean by this term uh so in sports and
specifically we're thinking of football
uh in this particular
application uh you have uh in the real
world uh sport coaches whose uh uh many
jobs include various forms of tactical
analysis uh of uh their team as well as
competing teams and figuring out uh both
the best tactics and the best
countertactics in response to what uh
opposing teams come up with so what do
we mean by an AI tactical assistant well
generally in order to come up with good
tactics and counter tactics you need to
be able to detect interesting Salient
actionable patterns uh in the football
game and the specific way in which you
come up with these patterns uh can be
quite tricky uh especially for human
observers if you have
to process large quantities of data
especially in a highly Dynamic
environment like football is
so an AI tactical assistant Might Be
Imagined as any kind of system that is
able to help human coaches make more
sense of the world of football through
uh very careful analyses of various
kinds of data such as tracking data
video data audio data or textual data
summarizing various matches and trying
to see what are the important Salient
features from which we can then come up
with more elaborate tactics in the
future
and it might also be interesting to
ponder this question from the opposite
direction like why would it be good for
us to like it's clear why the use of AI
might be helpful in sports analytics
there's a huge Dynamic stream of data
from a highly noisy and challenging
environment and uh basically artificial
intelligence one of the main selling
points of artificial intelligence is
that it can help us make sense of large
quantities of data like that but I feel
like it's also useful to study this
question in the opposite direction like
why uh is sports an interesting domain
for artificial
intelligence and in my personal opinion
there are three uh pretty interesting
points for why AI for sports and sports
coaching specifically is something that
is quite interesting first of all it
gives us a nice safe and controllable
test beted for AI research because uh we
are required by the nature of the
environment to produce uh interpretable
representations processing potentially a
multimodal stream of data and we need to
uh make decisions that uh are applicable
in a real world multi-agent system and
it's very rare to find a nice concoction
of these three properties so so clearly
lined up side by side and maybe it
should come as no surprise that then
Sports is a very interesting Melting Pot
of various disciplines of research like
computer vision Game Theory statistical
learning and so on and also uh in many
cases you can Define very clear metrics
that you can use to measure the progress
of your methods and track success of
your methods so there's many things
about sports as a domain which can be
quite favorable for artificial
intelligence research generally
speaking so uh along with many
collaborators at Google deep mind uh we
have set on a journey to try to exploit
artificial intelligence methods over
Sports data uh as much as we could and
our journey really starts around 2019
and so on uh and 20120 uh when we also
made our first visit to our
collaborators at Liverpool that you can
see in this picture over here and uh one
of the uh kind of uh one of the key
Publications which uh came out during
this period was the game plan paper uh
authored by Carl TOs and others
published at Jr where this avac or
automated video assistant coach uh um
concept is proposed now what do we mean
by the avac uh generally speaking you
might be interested in answering complex
questions about a football match for
example you have a camera which shows
you the state of a match at any
particular point in time and you might
be asking yourself then okay what has
happened off screen like what is
happening in this game that the camera
is not showing and this is actually a
really complex question to answer which
might rely on a lot of different aspects
of machine learning research for example
we might need some aspects of quality
representation learning to be able to
learn a system like this over large
quantities of multimodal data without
necessarily any structure attached to it
um then we might need to incorporate
some explicit aspects of predictive and
generative modeling to be able to reason
about what happens away from the field
of view of the camera and lastly uh in
order to make interpretable and useful
profiles coming out of these kinds of
systems uh we might also be interested
in game theoretic research on human
factors that allows us to more
explicitly model the specific traits of
individual players so really what goes
on when a system has to answer a
question like what happened off screen
there are a lot of very important
aspects that might fall into a system
that answers these kinds of questions
and the game plan paper is one very nice
overview paper that outlines the kinds
of things that need to go into a system
like
this building up on the initial results
uh outlined in game plan that motivate
This research Direction uh in 2021 uh
there have been several very important
external Outlets where we have cemented
our claim to Applications of AI for
sports and our commitment to uh further
research uh in this
area
um yeah uh basically uh first within one
of the popular artificial intelligence
conferences IAI 2021 we had organized a
workshop on AI for sports then uh Carl
TLS and along with two co-authors has
co-published a book on AI for sports
which is also a really interesting and
useful reference uh if you want to learn
more about it and for those who prefer
podcasts uh AI for sports also featured
in the second season of Deep Mind the
podcast with Hannah fry which is another
kind of very popular Outlet where we
showcased various aspects of our AI for
sports
research and this leads us to
2022 where uh moving from some of the
primary Concepts outlined in the game
plan we have actually been able to
publish uh a paper in nature scientific
reports called the graph imputer which
uh effectively is one of the first uh
kind of self-contained modules that
embed the kinds of predictive tasks that
a human coach might find particular
particularly useful and this uh was a
result of a very continued and onward
collaboration with Liverpool and which
also led to our second visit to
Liverpool and uh this was also around
the time when I have joined the project
so you can see me uh in the center of
this picture at Liverpool's training
grounds um and we won't talk in a lot of
depth about the graph Andor here but one
thing that is important to note about
the graph Ander is that it tries from
abstrac toied tracking data to answer
this question of what is happening off
camera so here you can see the
trajectories of various players in a
football game but uh a camera which is
showing you the live action in a
football game does not show you where
all the players are rather you can only
see the action of some of the players
which are near the ball and uh this is
problematic if you want to say analyze
how well is one particular player
behaving for example in a scouting
scenario if you want to detect potential
future players to to uh acquire for your
team um you might normally um uh you
might normally be uh sending scouts out
to watch the game live and track players
live but this is a potentially costly
process so it might be really really
useful if you could have a uh A system
that is capable of just watching the
video recording of a football match and
based on that figuring out how all the
players are behaving but this naturally
draws with it a complicated uh uh
problem of figuring out where are all
the players that are not on the camera
right now moving and this is what the
graph imputer set out to do using a
combination of graph machine learning
supervised learning and inspiration from
Game Theory graph imputer is capable of
basically generating probable sequences
of where each player is moving
regardless of whether whether or not
they are currently on camera or off
camera and systems like these uh can
perhaps be an important way to automate
some of the tasks that uh humans might
not be able to do
manually so the successes of graph
imputer have set us on a trajectory that
leads us to this year and in this year
we have actually set out to build a
complete system that might be able to
serve uh suggestions the human coaches
and uh to build a useful kind of fully
packaged system we need to be be able to
answer several categories of questions
which are closely intertwined with one
another as we will see later in this
talk so we might need to have a system
that's capable of answering questions
like what will happen in a particular
football situation this leads us to
predictive
modeling um you might be able to uh need
to answer the kinds of question of okay
provide something happened can you
analyze what actually happened so in
this case uh predict some embeddings
from your situations and use them to
support various forms of retrieval so
you can mine similar
situations and maybe one of the most
interesting problems in this scenario is
what could have happened if I wanted to
optimize for a particular outcome and
this is the guided generation objective
and uh satisfying these three kinds of
questions like being able to answer them
more efficiently is what led us to
develop tactic AI an AI assistant for
football tactics uh which uh is joint
work from Joe Wong myself Daniel henis
and many other great collaborators from
both deepmind and Liverpool Football
Club so in the remainder of this talk
I'll be telling you about tactic Ai and
how we've been able to uh build it using
the various uh uh using the various
components that you see outlined on this
slide over here
so I need to before we dive into tactic
Ki I feel like it's useful to mention
how these three Works uh that uh uh
Google deepmind and Liverpool worked on
together over the years kind of
gradually Ascend the ladder of automated
tactics assistance so game plan is
really a paper that answers the why like
gives some motivating examples for how a
while only like presenting a relatively
isolated qualitative study specifically
game plan looked at penalty kicks to
show that some forms of statistical
analysis can be quite useful there um
then graph imputer took this a step
further and tried to directly answer a
question of okay we have an idea we have
a feeling that AI could be useful to
assist football tactics now let's try to
answer the question of how can AI be
used to analyze football tactics so
graph imputer specifically looking at
the question of where are the players
moving off camera provides a concrete
prototype of a system that can automate
a task that is really challenging for
humans and lastly tactic AI is really
trying to give the what so what is an
example of a practical AI football
tactics assistant so what tactic AI does
is it doesn't just focus on one task or
motivating a particular task it really
aims to provide a full system that's
capable of providing useful suggestions
to a human coach and specifically to
make this claim a reality in our work we
focus on Corner kicks uh as a test bet
now I feel like it is important to try
to motivate why do we specifically focus
on Corner kicks here and maybe let's
take a step back first and think about
the specifics of having to do predictive
or generative modeling inside the game
of
football as you might imagine football
is a highly dynamic sport that's really
hard to influence like even if you had a
really powerful system that was capable
in real time to tell you uh what aspects
of tactics are working out or not
working out it would be really tricky to
make changes to these tactics in real
time and you know even if you were able
to do it you might end up confusing the
players because they need to keep their
uh their minds focused on the game
that's taking place in real time right
so making any real on thefly suggestion
is actually quite tricky in open
football play so that's not as easy of a
domain to deploy uh you know packaged
products that make useful
suggestions however fortunately for us
there exist uh many moments in the
football match known as set pieces such
as this Liverpool corner kick that you
can see here and during a corner kick
the game state is effectively Frozen
because the ball is placed in the corner
the different different players are
orienting themselves and the corner
taker then drives the action that will
happen afterwards so this now is a
setting where the game is not moving as
dynamically as it would in full open
play and there might be ways in which we
can make suggestions that are actually
influential and by the way some of you
have probably seen the movie Moneyball
which uh if you haven't I recommend
taking a look at it it's another good
example of using statistical methods uh
in improving Sports analytics one of the
reasons why Moneyball was so effective
in the game of baseball is because in
some sense in baseball every single game
step is a set piece right every single
action step in baseball all the players
are frozen in place and uh a new um and
a new uh basically uh um a new situation
arises where you can come up with new
kinds of Statistics that you can decide
on uh how to distribute your players
which players to acquire and so on and
so
forth
okay and so assuming that set pieces are
a relevant place where we can uh
influence uh uh our
analysis uh there are four main types of
set pieces in football penalties throwin
free kicks and Corner kicks penalties uh
also make a very interesting setting to
study here and in fact the game plan
paper already studies penalties in more
detail but out of these four really
Corner kicks are the ideal candidate why
so because first of all they're frequent
every single football game has a quite
sizable number of corner Kicks On
average they are quite rigid they always
take place from the same situation that
is the ball is always in the corner
whereas with free kicks uh you depend on
where exactly a foul has taken place in
order to uh you know in order to decide
from which position you're taking the
free kick and also uh in every situation
a corner kick will give you an
opportunity to immediately score a goal
right Corners are really the only set
piece in football that give you these
three properties at the same time and
maybe it should come as no surprise then
that the strategies for Corners to allow
for them to be executed in the most
smooth possible way are often decided up
front before a game even takes place so
if you have a good corner kick analysis
system you can definitely use this uh to
actionably influence uh how a particular
game might
unfold so accordingly to make tactic Ai
and actually immediately useful system
we make it a corner kick analysis
system now once we have decided we want
to uh focus on studying corner kick
situations let's talk a little bit about
how we can build a machine learning
model to deal with those
situations and specifically in tactic AI
uh we are focused on under understanding
the different relations between the
players and perhaps in the setting of
Corners this becomes all the more
important because various player
synergies can be significantly exploited
when designing tactics and
countertactics and corners and one very
nice data structure to model implicit
relations between objects are graphs so
uh accordingly we focus uh on uh we
focus on uh graph neural networks as
assist system uh as a machine learning
model that can process these kinds of uh
these kinds of situations now
specifically what do I mean by this so
whenever I show you a corner situation
like this well here with only six
players but just to make the
illustration more clear what the mo
machine learning model actually sees is
tracking data of each one of these
individual players and we represent them
as nodes in a graph where each node and
each Edge in the graph has a certain
feature Vector associated with
properties of that player and any
properties between Pairs of players that
we're aware of such as are they on the
same team or not and then this
particular graph structure with node
features corresponding to player vectors
and Edge features corresponding to
player synergies or uh equal or uh not
equal teams can then be sent across to a
graph machine learning method which
usually will employ some form of message
passing message passing in a nutshell is
just an operation that updates the
representations of each player starting
from this input vectors X into some
latent space Vector H in a way that
directly depends on the representations
of all of the neighboring nodes or in
this particular case if we use a fully
connected graph all of the other nodes
and the features of the neighboring
nodes and the features of the
corresponding edges will drive the
specific messages that are being sent
sent across this graph and based on the
aggregation of those messages you will
compute updated features for each player
now this is a very neat analogy because
you can very nicely stick various kinds
of features at various granularities in
this graph so as we already mentioned in
node features you can put various player
properties like their playing positions
velocities Heights weights and their
ball possession during the game uh in
the edge features you can uh for example
put a binary flag telling you are these
two players on the same team or not and
you can even put features that are
Global on the level of the entire graph
such as where are the Home and Away
goalpost positions what's the time of
day what's the weather conditions and
these kinds of things what's the current
score and this then also allows you to
easily specify a plethora of various
predictive tasks so you can predict
whether or not a shot has taken place uh
uh in this corner as graph
classification you can try to predict
which player will receive the ball after
the corner as a node classification and
you can try to predict positions and
velocities of various players also as
node
regression and we did not actually stop
at graph machine learning because this
was a great way to process uh data
corresponding to a collection of player
nodes but uh another problem that we had
to deal with is the fact that uh in real
world football games there's not really
that many games taking place every
season so there's not a lot of data that
you can use to train a system like this
especially if you are focusing mainly on
Corners so we had to exploit the
methodology that allows us to explicitly
encode some useful symmetries of the
football pitch to help to hopefully
reduce the uh solution space that our
neural network is searching
for so what this means is that if we
have a input Corner situation like this
what we can then do is generate all the
different variants of this situation
where we would expect the answer to be
exactly the same so specifically one
such transformation that we employ
heavily in our work are horizontal and
vertical Reflections right so this is a
very nice symmetry of the football pitch
if I were to reflect my football pitch
either horizontal horizontally or
vertically it is for all intents and
purposes can be considered the same
situation and as a result uh uh my model
should ideally give me the same answers
in these four situations so what we do
is we generate all four of these
transformed situations then we feed them
through tactic AI Central model as we
discussed before each one of these blue
arrows is effectively a graph neural
network with message passing over each
of the four situations that we discussed
uh in the middle and once uh a joint
representation over these four views is
computed
you can then answer various questions
about this corner kick situation like
who makes first contact with the ball
which as we said would be a node
classification problem uh will a shot be
taken or not which as we said is a graph
classification problem and uh we can
also compute interesting adjustments
which is the guided generation so can we
figure out adjusted positions of the
players to increase or decrease shot
probability and if you exploit geomet
deep learning in this way it can be
highly beneficial for data efficiency
because now your model does not have to
relearn that these four Reflections
should be processed identically your
model is mathematically forcing the
model to behave in this way and uh this
is very useful because in football
unlike most deep learning applications
we don't really have a lot of gold
standard data with only about a 100
games played every season and uh the way
we use uh the geometric deep learning
blueprint will depend on the way in
which you're symmetry is Manifest if
your tasks are invariant like receiver
or shot prediction right so the identity
of the receiver or whether or not a shot
happened doesn't change with the
reflection then you can predict based on
the average of all the four frames
you've generated but sometimes your
tasks might be what is known as
equivariant like if you want to predict
adjusted player positions if you have
reflected the pitch then the predicted
positions should also be reflected they
don't stay the same so in these
situations we don't predict based on the
average of all frames but we predict
based on the identity frames
View and you can then kind of put all of
these predictions together and look at
for example guided Generations which is
one of the outputs tactic AI can provide
for you so to see what guided
Generations can do let's consider this
particular corner here in this
particular Corner a shot has happened
for the attacking team in red and uh
I've highlighted a few specific parts of
the situation
so you can see uh so you can focus on
them when I show you an adjustment
proposed by tactic
AI so tactic AI is then capable of
predicting updated positions and
velocities for the defending players
such that the probability of a shot as
predicted by its shot prediction model
is reduced and uh in this particular
case I specifically draw your attention
to these three red and yellow circles uh
the players that are relevant for these
three circles are now positioned better
and they make more active more
intercepting movement to block uh the
three corresponding attackers two three
and four and these things do not only
these changes do not only have an effect
on reducing shot probability they also
affect the tactic AI receiver predictor
uh specifically previously you might
have had a higher receiving probability
for attackers 2 three and four which are
in the Box actually making these
adjustments to the defensive players now
drastically increases the probability
that attacker one which is far away in
the back will receive the ball which
further emphasizes that uh under this
positioning of the defense the red team
will might not have as much success as
before in uh sending the ball into the
box so the attacking team is now less
likely to do this
successfully now we've built a system
like this right it can predict the
receivers it can predict shot events and
it can predict these guided Generations
such that they uh increase or decrease
shot probability I will have to start by
giving you the quantitative numbers of
how well it can do those three things uh
as using a machine learning evaluation
but very quickly I will show you why I
don't think we should focus too much on
these numbers so in terms of receiver
prediction the best model that we've
been able to build has about 78% top
three accuracy so if you take the top
three predictions for the receiver of
the corner that are given by tactic AI
in about 78% of the cases the correct
ground truth receiver will be in those
top three
suggestions on shot prediction uh we
have been able to achieve an F1 score of
0.64 which uh is not a particularly
strong predictive power but is
definitely stronger than
chance and uh when we use guided
generation we can significantly adjust
the defending team to reduce the
predicted shot probabilities in
situations where shots have happened and
note here so we reduce the average shot
probability in various situations from
75% to
69% and this uh change is very
statistically significant with a P value
less than
01 similarly we can use tactic AI to
adjust attacking team positions to
increase the shot probability for
Corners where shots did not happen uh
Argo increasing the shot probability
from 18% to 31% once again with high
statistical
significance and lastly because it's not
just enough to put your players in a
different position to increase or
decrease shot probability if you do this
in a way that produces a highly
unrealistic Corner such that you know
it's quite obvious that the attacker or
the defending players would not do this
without the response we checked whether
you can actually distinguish the corners
generated by tactic AI from real Corners
that happened and to do this we trained
a simple MLP classifier to check uh
whether a corner is real or adjusted and
the F1 score of this classifier was
about 0.5 which is basically random
chance accuracy so at least you cannot
train a machine learning model to tell
apart tactic AI Corners versus real
Corners now I do not think that you
should dwell too much on these numbers I
feel like they're important just from a
perspective of machine learning analysis
but recall what we're trying to build
here we're trying to build a system
that's actually useful for human experts
so while quantitative metrics are useful
if you want to publish a machine
learning paper they don't always really
indicate how easily can a human make
advantage of such a system and in the
context of football predictive power
might not tell you that much because
whether or not a pass or a shot will
happen May well depend on lot of things
that our model just doesn't see for
example you know human psychology how
are the individual players feeling how
stressed they are what are the weather
conditions how tired the players are and
so on right there are many things that
we do not put in the features of our
models that might very well impact which
player is the most likely receiver or
whether or not a shot will take place
that you know some I would argue you
cannot really achieve 100% or close to
100% accuracy on these tasks so I don't
think this is the right metric to
optimize for so we wanted to really
tackle this problem head-on and let's
evaluate how useful such a systems
output is to humans so we organized the
human case study with five expert
Raiders from Liverpool and these five
Raiders included coaching assistants
video analysts and data scientists and
over the course of the study we showed
them over 300 examples of corner kcks
asking them various questions over them
and these Corners were both real and
tactic AI generate
adjustments so first a very important
question we said we couldn't train a
machine learning model to tell apart
real Corners versus tactic adjustments
can humans tell tactic adjustments apart
from Corners no they can't so here on
the right hand side you see the average
realism scores assigned to real and
generated corners and you can see
they're basically the same distribution
and uh these adjustments are
indistinguishable with the P bigger than
5% so basically uh as far as realism is
concerned tactic adjustments are
indistinguishable from real
Corners so that's a good first start
then secondly to validate how good our
predictive metrics were we asked our
various human Raiders to uh predict you
know with top three
accuracy uh who is the likely receiver
of a particular corner and what we found
quite satisfying was that humans on
average had a top three accuracy of
about 79% and this is a percentage that
if you remember a few slides ago is
comparable with tactic ai's percentage
and what's also very important is that
uh there's no significant difference in
the accuracy of uh predicting who's the
receiver of a real Corner versus
predicting who's the receiver of a
tactic AI generated corner where
obviously you don't have ground truth
labels but they come from tactic AI but
the fact that the agreement still s
stays roughly indistinguishable from the
real corners shows that once again the
predictions coming out of our predictive
model are well aligned with uh with
human
intuitions so as a one- sentence summary
of these two results experts cannot
distinguish tactic adjustments from real
corners and experts predict corner kick
receivers equally well as tactic AI
these are not necessarily the main
questions we want answered but they're
important starting points right if
tactic AI produces obviously fake
Corners then that's not necessarily a
tactic you can use uh in in the real
world next up because tactic AI has to
build these player representations that
can help them answer all sorts of
questions about the corner kick
situation like who's the receiver or
whether a shot is
taken arguably tactic a has to build up
an interesting uh embedding space
representation of players and therefore
you would expect that tactic ki's player
embedding space here visualized using
tne can result in some very interesting
structure assigned to various Corners so
we're going to study a couple of
situations in this t space you can
already see them highlighted with yellow
circles I will now gradually expand
those yellow circles uh into various
corner kick
situations so one thing you might expect
and it definitely does happen we've
observed it in many cases is that corner
kicks uh that are structurally very
similar tend to receive very similar
embeddings from tactic AI so here for
example you can see two corners that are
very close in the latent space of tactic
Ai and you can already see the three
motifs highlighted in purple and white
uh showing that actually structurally
these two corners are very similar and
they seem like very similar strategies
and you can also see that the swing type
uh is the same in both Corners so the
strategy for where where the ball is
being sent uh is also the same and and
also as you would usefully expect um uh
if you have uh Corners that are embedded
far apart in the embedding space they
tend to have dissimilar motifs and in
this particular case these two corners
that are on the opposite ends of the um
of the spectrum uh they will correspond
to an inswing and an outswing Corner
respectively and those two corners are
generally quite different situations
from a tactical analysis
perspective so these kinds of isolated
qualitative observations lead us to
believe that tactic AI could be quite
useful as a retrieval system and this is
another task that you know human uh
assistant coaches have to do on a
regular basis whenever you are playing
against a new team uh you might find it
very useful to analyze what kind of
corner strategies they've been having
over the past games so retrieval of
similar situations to any particular
situation
is potentially a very valuable tool for
learning more about strategies to employ
against this team and anticipate what
kind of tactics they will have so we
wanted to validate how well could tactic
K embeddings be used for retrieval now
this is not a scenario where you can do
a very comprehensive study because
there's many different ways in which you
can do retrieval but we wanted to see
just as a simple first sanity check can
tactic AI help us retrieve corners in a
more interesting way than if we just
looked at Raw player positions which is
what a more simple heuristic could do so
we built a simple heuristic using raw
feature similarity so we compare two
situations by how close they are in the
player coordinate space and we retrieve
a corner Which is closest in terms of
player coordinates and this kind of
retrieval has been seen as useful by
human experts about 33% of the time so
for 33% of the situations T choosing the
the closest corner uh to Any Given
Corner in terms of input player
coordinates uh gives you a usefully
similar retrieved Corner about 33% of
the time if instead you choose to
retrieve a similar Corner based on how
similar their tactic AI player
embeddings are you suddenly get uh a
success rate of about 63% which is
obviously quite a significant
Improvement compared to this raw feature
Baseline and what's also encouraging
about it is that all of this uh to make
the case study more scalable is done in
the uh um k equals one regime so we're
only retrieving one similar Corner
whereas in reality an analyst May
retrieve five or 10 similar Corners
which obviously will amplify this
probability that you will find something
useful within
them so uh if you look at the specific
ratings assigned to whether or not the
retrieval is useful uh the ones assigned
to tactic retrievals are significantly
higher than when you're using raw
features and this is statistically
significant and also it's not just that
on average tactic Ki embeddings are more
useful our five Raiders are highly in
agreement on which Corners are useful
and which Corners are not useful so all
five of them find tactic AI to be
significantly better than raw features
and the level of inter rator agreement
is pretty
high so in summary for the retrieval
study experts prefer tactic a based
retrievals to retrievals based on
directly looking at the raw player
features and experts have a high degree
of agreement over this rating so it's
not just that on average they find it
better every single one of them seems to
be in general High agreement over which
uh features are Salient and which ones
are
not and now we come to the main question
right we mentioned that we can use
tactic K as a predictive model we
mentioned you can use tactic K as a
retrieval model but really the most
interesting thing tactic K can do is do
the guided Generations so suggest
different tactics or suggest
modifications to what different players
could be doing in a certain corner kick
situation to hopefully increase or
decrease shot probability or probability
of any particular event so we set up um
a comparative study where we showed our
expert Raiders uh two corners one of
them is the adjustment of another and we
assign a rating of plus one if tactic
improves the situation minus one if it
makes the situation worse and zero if
there's no
difference so this gives us a score in
the range of plus one to minus one and
first really uh exciting result is that
averaged over all the scenarios we
showed to our Raiders the average rating
assigned was
0.7 which is a pretty pretty high rating
compared to the width of the range but
maybe an even more tangible result is on
how many of the corners we showed was on
average it seemed to be a good
suggestion and that number is 90% so in
90% of all of the situations we showed
to our human experts they by consensus
agreed that uh the suggestions from
tactic aai were
useful and once again just like for the
retrieval case this is not just like an
average of some Raiders being very happy
with tactic Ai and some Raiders maybe
being a bit less happy the inter rator
agreement is very high which means that
uh uh the the the human experts largely
agreed on where the suggestions were
Salient and where they were
not so this is arguably the most
important quantitative result of our
work we have seen that the system can be
directly useful because experts prefer
tactic AI suggestions over real tactics
90% of the time and we've seen before
they cannot tell them apart from real
situations which is also really
important so these are important
suggestions and they're ones that feel
realistic and once again experts are not
this is not just on average experts have
a high degree of agreement over the
ratings that they have
assigned and while looking at all these
numbers is probably very interesting to
evaluate how well the model is behaving
in the aggregate I feel like there's
always an exciting aspect of analyzing
model outputs directly so I want to show
you here four specific situations where
tactic AI made suggestions where most or
all of our five Raiders thought yeah
these players are really importantly
modified so
here on the left hand side you have um a
reference Corner that happened in an
actual Premier League match and on the
right hand side you have Suggestions by
tactic AI on the defensive team such
that that the probability of scoring for
the attacking team is reduced and all
the players that have a circle around
them are players where our uh expert
coaches have thought that this was an
important
adjustment and uh the brighter the
yellow circle the more experts have said
that this is important and this is a
very interesting case because actually
all of the defending players except for
one have been seen as Salient
suggestions here
and you can generally see that they are
being a lot more active they are
positioned better the goalkeeper is
moved further back Which is less risky
and the runs that the defending players
are making are far more closely tracking
some of the attackers than before this
is a pretty important uh thing to note
because the system was never explicitly
trained uh to do these kinds of
heuristics it has learned them
completely by itself by uh learning how
to predict which features are associated
with shots and which features are
associated with receivers and then
optimizing the predicted positions such
that uh this uh prediction is optimized
in one or the other
direction here is another interesting
example once again a lot of the players
on the defending team have seen salian
suggestions and you can generally see
especially in the cluster of the
defending players that are closer to the
edge of the Box uh there's now a lot
more Dynamic movement which tries to
close up the movements of the various
attacking players uh in a way that
hopefully will stop the threat a lot
more effectively than than the more
stationary approach from the reference
Corner
does here is another situation where you
can focus now on the four players in the
center of the box once again in the
first case they all sort of ran off in a
potentially in correct direction which
doesn't really seek to block anyone
whereas in the refinement they are now
tracking their Runners a lot better and
covering a lot more ground more
effectively and the fourth situation
which uh is uh maybe an example of a
less Global but more targeted suggestion
that tactic Ki gave I think we can put
most of our attention on the two Central
defending players which previously were
making relatively weak runs which did
not have a chance of strongly blocking
the attackers and those were both now
modified to include more proper tracking
and covering runs of the corresponding
attackers and these two have been seen
as very Salient by the uh by the expert
Raiders so this was the last slide I
wanted to show you let's talk about some
conclusions not that we've covered all
of this in our work we studied a dynamic
set of problems all roughly revolving
around inferring corner kick Dynamics X
and our method was powered by graph
neural networks and geometric deep
learning as a result it it meant we had
increased data efficiency and we were
able to cope with uh the challenging
data availability constraints uh in
association football and our model is
both predictive and generative so we can
predict whether or not there will be a
particular outcome uh in a football
match like a shot or a receiver event
but we can also have a generative model
that can predict
how should the players have been
positioned to increase or decrease shot
probabilities and the adjustments
produced are both realistic and
quantifiable and what's more important
is that they are also deemed on average
and in terms of agreement significantly
useful by Liverpool Football Club
experts and in a domain of corner kicks
where you can actually make actionable
decisions based on the outputs of this
model in a relatively clear way so in
short as we set out to build an AI
assistant for football tactics We
believe We Now indeed have an AI
assistant for football tactics in our
hands hope you've enjoyed it thank you
very much for listening and uh I will
obviously be happy to take any questions
you might have uh I'd like to thank once
again all of the great collaborators
that worked with us on this both within
Google Deep Mind and within Liverpool
Football Club and yeah I remain
available for any any other points of
discussion you have either during the
Q&A session or afterwards if you want to
reach out I have my email contact and my
social networks on this slide uh lastly
I would like to thank Vash for inviting
me to speak to you all today this is
actually the first time I'm presenting
this line of work externally so yeah
really Keen to to hear more about your
feedback thank you very much thanks a
lot P it's great to to have this
presentation here first and we do have a
couple of uh questions however I wanted
to ask first uh to make it more General
so in the end end what you are looking
for is a recommendation system that was
validated with uh uh how to say it with
uh answers from the the team from
Liverpool Football Club is is that
correct like the whole to make it uh to
name
it right so I mean I guess the result we
are most excited about our
recommendations in terms of suggested
adjustments to player positions and
velocities and things like that but it
turns out in order to build a good
generative system like that you also
need to have a system that really
understands the game so I believe all of
the artifacts we developed along the way
like predictors of receiver
probabilities or predictors of shot
probabilities or even these side uh
artifacts like you know retrieval
systems based on the embeddings are all
bound to be very useful but we basically
Focus like you know the main output we
were really hoping would work out well
was the generative suggestions and
indeed we were quite happy with the
qualitative results weed so you've had
in mind when uh approaching this problem
you've had in mind uh the whole full
architecture of the solution or did you
approach it incrementally and an idea
came up somewhere in the end that there
might be a useful input from uh one part
of uh The Works to be used for
uh another
one uh I would say yes and no on this
question because first of all um we sort
of knew what the good architecture over
the tracking data would look like
because we had the graph imputer model I
showed you before so we already sort of
knew in the team how to build a model
that understands tracking data and
player nodes reasonably well but I would
say that uh there was still an element
of being incremental about it because
especially in corner situations there
were lots of these these pitch
symmetries that we could exploit so the
idea to attach geometric deep learning
on top of the graph neural network only
came later during the development of the
model so yeah basically maybe we knew
which tasks we wanted to predict uh you
know prior uh to starting the project
and we knew it should be some kind of a
graph machine learning model but uh the
full architecture was something we
developed step by step all right thank
you let's ask the questions from the
audience because there are some uh so
first uh is uh what makes AI in this
aspect better than say an assistant
coach with experience what I believe is
how can you go beyond what uh himon is
capable in terms of
assisting right so looking at the time
stamp this is a great question but
looking at the time stamp I think this
question was asked somewhat earlier in
talk before before I introduced uh you
know graph imputer and all of those
different approaches so hopefully by now
it's a bit clearer what kinds of tasks
AI is able to Zone in on that a human
assistant coach with experience cannot
but I will elaborate on it again because
I think it's a useful question to ponder
um
basically I would not deny that an
assistant coach if they're really
focused on a particular situation would
probably be able to detect a lot of the
things that tactic Ki is able to detect
that being said um it does require some
effort to spot the right patterns
especially in a sea of 22 players that
are sometimes really close to each other
and figuring out really what are the
Salient collections of players and also
so not only is it tricky to spot you
might miss something if you over fixate
on a particular Motif that you're very
familiar with and uh I think one thing
tactic I can help you with is basically
pretty much immediately output to you
hey these parts of the corner are
looking interesting these players might
be a bit falling asleep on the job or
you might need to adjust their position
a little bit so these kinds of immediate
feedbacks can basically help accelerate
the rate at which the human experts are
able to do their job and analyze more
situations and maybe even detect novel
variations that they might not
immediately think of because they're not
explicitly familiar with them so I would
say it doesn't necessarily and to to to
to be honest with you this is really the
most exciting kinds of AI applications
in my opinion like they don't
necessarily invent this brand new skill
the AI assistant that the human
assistant coach didn't already have but
they allow them to do their job much
more efficiently and uh basically come
up with more leave more time for
creativity and less time for like
mundane pattern hunting yeah sure for
for the new futur to Pro probably very
difficult to be validate it if it would
came beyond what human do uh actually I
I feel uh all right then next question
is can it be implemented in the real
time or only retrospectively as you said
you it was difficult to to make it
online
system yeah so I think you can Implement
a system like this in real time like I
think speed-wise it's not really a big
problem but what I would say though is
that like my my claim was more that you
don't really want to do decision making
in real time because you know the
players will easily get confused if you
shout instructions at them in the middle
of the game I think like you really need
to focus on what's happening right so
Corners are a really good candidate here
because actually the corner kick
strategies are decided before a game
even begins right so you can actually
you know influence that strategy
building aspect before the game even
takes place by using the kinds of
analysis that ttic K offers so to answer
this question I think you could
Implement something like this in real
time and maybe even make some kind of
immediate adjustments maybe you can well
one thing you could do I guess is
substitutions like you could decide to
substitute certain players in if you see
that they would be giving you a much
higher shot probability in certain
scenarios or something like this or if
they are you know less fatigued than
other players and so on but uh I would
argue most of the salian decisions still
should not happen in real time I would
say because you you have a risk of
introducing confusion if you do this
yeah another one is uh comment I read
your paper amazing work thank you hover
I'm a little confused as to why you only
consider the position height and weight
in your work for describing a player
skill in
Aral yeah this is an excellent question
I see it's a multiple part question so
thanks Andre for asking this uh I would
say maybe I should have more explicitly
said it we deliberately focus on a very
minimal set of features just to show you
you know with some data that can be
readily available to most football clubs
you can make a difference already and
make Salient suggestions in reality a
lot of these things become more nuanced
when you introduce various player
profiles for example you know uh as
mentioned you know skill rating systems
on aerial dual skills and things like
that um which you know as you go deeper
into the specifics of features you go
deeper into you know what each
individual Club is Computing and capable
of inferring based on the data available
to them so you know this now falls into
the realm of what individual clubs might
do with uh with this kind of data we
really deliberately focused on data
that's fairly generic just to show that
the idea works even if you take away a
lot of that Nuance but of course I would
expect the model to perform a lot better
if it has access to uh these kinds of
additional features right note another
thing that we're not using at all is uh
where the ball is and which direction
the ball is moving all we know is at the
moment the corner is taken where each
player is and and which direction
they're going in that's all our model
knows so with more data you can have
more accurate models as well of course
all right and uh another follow-up uh
one is uh that uh we could calculate to
win percentage in the previous matches
which might help to simulate cor Corners
more
accurately yeah so this is this is
basically what I I saw that all these
questions came from the same person I my
answer to all of them in the same one uh
all right so uh if you have any more
questions uh just taking the audience uh
fre to ask them uh one thing I was
curious about uh because uh the tactic
AI module is uh outputting the
embeddings to the Disney itself or do
you call do you call tactic AI like the
whole system I was B in into this
one ah so so the tne thing is really
just to make it prettier to look at and
actually make sense of the space in
reality it's a higher dimensional space
which we cannot visualize right uh
really like you know the tne is there
for us to just have visual inspections
and the retrieval takes place over a
much higher dimensional space that we
cannot easily plot on a slide that being
said a tne could still be useful if you
want to design like a tool where a human
can like explore the latent space of
corners and like look at similar Corners
by clicking on them but I would argue
because you're doing a dimensionality
reduction by doing a tisne you are
effectively destroying some of the
useful structure that tactic a has
learned by by doing that so yeah I would
I would probably you know I wouldn't use
tne uh as the actual uh Vector used to
mine similar corners but it can be a
really cool visualization technique and
uh so for us the TC analysis was really
just to see that we believe there's
something useful happening in this
latent space and we have some
qualitative evidence for that and that
then motivated us to do the you know
case study with humans uh yeah yeah I
thought maybe that was used for uh for
the ranking like you had it clustered
and then you knew that there is uh some
part of Cates uh that you could put use
the answers from as a result but uh as
you said it's only for the visual
aspects yeah yeah it's more blind than
that just take the closest one in the
embedding space we're not really trying
to hunt for clusters at this point all
right uh there is one more question does
the system change according to the team
or does that not make a
difference so okay currently the
currently the model does not have
information over the identities of the
teams which obviously would help it
doesn't have access to the current score
or the weather or these kinds of
features that can all influence like
what kinds of strategies or or success
rates you could have once again this all
falls into the realm of additional
features you can introduce into the
model um obviously in some sense the
system will change according to the team
just because the player vectors are
going to be uh the player vectors are
going to be different for the two teams
right so uh in that sense when you put a
different team into tactic Ki or you
substitute certain players you will get
different outputs right um but there's
no explicit team
identifiers in the in the prediction no
all right thank you and maybe last
question because we are running out of
time I was curious about uh when you're
using the graph NE Network for uh for
this kind of uh task do you
somehow uh make different iterative
approach to re wiring that uh input
graph uh so that you can see the
difference
uh in between each uh let's say
recommendation and
suggestion right so we do not do this uh
in this particular paper mainly because
in football the number of nodes is not
that big right it's 22 so it's like
there there's whenever a graph is that
small my general and when you don't have
to generalize to bigger graphs that's
also an important aspect my generalistic
is that fully connected graphs tend to
be a pretty good idea and it's really
hard come up with like you know rigid
sparse graphs that will do a better job
that being said the if you read through
our paper I obviously didn't have enough
time to cover all those in-depth details
but our main architecture is a graph
attention Network meaning that we do
have an attention mechanism over the
edges and uh while we don't have these
results in the paper we have like
informally analyzed what are the graph
structures that this model kind of
learns to build and there is some loose
correspondence between how strong
attention coefficients you compute and
like player synergies as sort of loosely
estimated by how much do these two
players like to pass with each other and
things like that although we never
explicitly put this feature in the model
and when we showed this to folks from
Liverpool I think they were interested
in the correlations coming out of the
system but we were not completely
convinced how we can kind of usefully
make advantage of such a system to drive
decision- making so basically you know
it was deprioritized compared to
everything else I showed you today but
yeah I think from the perspective of
like looking at attention coefficients
there's definitely some interesting
rewiring happening implicitly inside
inside the
system uh all right last question who
can use tactical AI is it uh for the
Liverpool or not sure if it's
confidential or not
but uh I mean the I think we mentioned
this in the our papers method section
the base models that ttiki uses are
models from uh github's sorry deep M's
GitHub repository of Cl rs30 which is
publicly available so the exact model
that we use minus the geometric deep
learning part which I think you can
easily slap on top of it uh is already
publicly available and there is open
source code um the data uh you know the
data is something that depends on what
you're able to get I do believe there
exists some open repositories of
football data you can play with um the
specific data we used was proprietary
but that doesn't mean that you know if
you don't have if you have access to a
particular data set you want to deploy
it on you wouldn't be able to do that so
I would say tactic AI the model can be
used by anyone and large parts of it are
effectively already open source um but
finding good data to put into tactic Ki
that depends on who you are and what
kind of data you would like to play with
so yeah yeah sure thanks again P for all
the us the presentation itself and for
accepting the invitation was pleasure
for us to to have you today and uh any
any uh any closing thoughts from your
s uh well thanks again uh for inviting
me for this event wos it was a nice and
dynamic opportunity to present our work
uh I also really enjoyed the
interactions with everybody who asked
questions and uh yeah I hope to uh have
a chance to present to you all again
once we have some other new significant
result come out uh in the future so
thanks again for the opportunity sure
thing thank you so uh thanks to all who
asked questions as well I really
appreciate it and uh once again P thank
you and